un récord de 35 mil contagios por corona
virus fue reportado el viernes en
california un nuevo y preocupante
aumento las unidades de cuidados
intensivos que se acercan a su capacidad
máxima el número de muertes aquí se ha
duplicado en los últimos cinco días
definitivamente estoy un poco preocupado
ya sabes tomando más precauciones de lo
habitual no quieres terminar en la uci y
darte cuenta que no hay suficientes
camas el coronavirus continúa dejando
registros cada vez más sombríos a través
de eeuu mientras que el país registró
más de 3.000 muertes el miércoles el
nivel más alto en un solo día desde que
comenzó la pandemia los expertos
advierten que el número de muertos
probablemente empeore el incremento de
los contagios ha hecho que varios
estados anuncien nuevas restricciones
incluyendo la costa este de pensilvania
y nueva york texas y florida también
están luchando para contener la
propagación este hospital de houston
está sintiendo la presión el 'coco' es
decir está golpeando a houston en
general bastante mal el coi se está
volviendo muy duro a todos los estados
cuando escuchas que cada 30 segundos
un americano muere sabes que estamos en
un gran
los funcionarios de salud señalan como
fuente del pico de contagios las
reuniones de acción de gracias y ahora
están estando a una mayor vigilancia
durante las festividades de fin de año
mientras que arroja luz al final de un
largo túnel la vacuna para ser valiente
que no tendrá ningún impacto
significativo hasta la mitad de 2021
según el principal experto en
enfermedades infecciosas de estados
unidos anthony fauci